サッブパパッサアカラナン
クサラッサウパサンパダ
サチッッタパリオダパナン
エータンブッダヌサーサナン
では よろしくお願いします
早速話に入ります この間
横浜にも講演会がありましてね
まあ大失敗しまして 余計なことをしゃべりすぎちゃって
で 講演の半分しか終了することはできませんでした
で そういうわけで 今日はあんまり余計な話をしないでね
皆様方 理解しようがしまいが全然気にしないで
もう で ざーっとしゃべればいいんじゃないかなと
まあわかりやすくしようとするところで
かなり時間がなくなってしまいますね
で 今日のテーマはね 善を行う力ということで
忍耐に 何でしたっけ？堪忍の本当の意味ということでね
別社の皆様で そんな本当の意味か知らなくてもどうでもいいではないかなと思うかもしれませんだけど
まあおそらくこの仏教の言葉を使ったりすると
なんだこれはというふうに疑問にはなります
はい このこれは結構皆様も丸丸暗記なさっている
サッブパパサカラナンという 3つの偈なんですね
あの 初仏の教えというね
であの 教会が出している経典のテキストにもある教えで
大体瞑想なさる方々はみんな暗記していますね
で そちらに出る言葉なんですね
その偈の中で偈を終わるときは
エータンブッダヌサーサナン
これは初仏の教えである
すべてのブッダたちの教えであると
そこはキーワードなんです
エータンブッダヌサーサナン
それで理解しやすい短い言葉の最後に
これは初仏の教えであると締めるんですね
なんだ この意味は ブッダっていうのは真理を発見したって意味なんですね
だから 小学者 独覚者 阿羅漢というね
まあカテゴリー 3つありますけど
みんなブッダなんですね
広い意味で だからお釈迦様にもザ・ブッダと言うんですね
ブッダっていうのは名前ではないんです
で シャーキヤムニなんですね
名前はね あるいはシッダールタ・ガウタマ
ザ・ブッダと言うんですね
ということは 悟った人は誰でもブッダっていう意味なんですね
そこでザ・ブッダといえばお釈迦様になるんです
英語で使うときも まあそこはまあア・ブッダとは
ア・ブッダと言ったら
どなたか悟った人 ザ・ブッダといえばお釈迦様というふうに区別するんです
ということは これは真理を発見した人の言葉です
だから ものすごい完全な意味なんですね
普遍性のある 誰にも違いますよと言えることはできない
すごい もう絶対的な言葉っていう意味なんですね
だから私たちは経典解説とか
そういうキーワードまず見つけて
このキーワードに乗って解説していくんです
だからこれは一般の方々にはなかなかキーワードは何なのかと見つからないかもしれません
それでサッブパパサカラナンクサラッサウパサンパダサチッッタパリオダパナンという 3つの条件がございまして
みんなそちらに引っかかっているんですね
まあエータンブッダはわかりやすいやと
でもそれはリフレインで繰り返しちゃうんですね
そこで私たちはそこから始まるんです
ここはキーワードですと
単純に理解して軽視するのではない
だから だって悪いことするなよと
そんなのはどんなアホでも知ってますよと
いいことしますよ そんなのは子供でも知ってますよと
これがダメなんです そんなアホに子供にできることじゃないんです
ブッダが言ってるんだから
小学者の教えのすべて省略している言葉です
これから本当かなと調べてみましょう
まず 第1偈に入ります
サッブパパッサアカラナン
一切の悪を起こさない
起こさないことなんですね
これはどうやって実践するのかと
人は自分知ってる範囲の悪をやめることから始めて
悪と定義できるいかなる行為もやめることにするんです
だから真理を発見していない私が
自分で知っている悪をね
やめるんです 人は何言ったってもいいんです
実践するのは自分だから
だから悟ってもないし
頭も悪いし もうどうしようもない自分が
まあ自分が知ってる範囲で悪行為をやめる
これやめてみたら なんか次の行為は善でしょうかと
言ったら 考えればこれもやめた方がいいんじゃないとわかるんですね
例えば ある人が酒も飲んでタバコも吸っている
そこで本人が仏教をちょこちょこと聞いたら
タバコを吸うなかれとおっしゃってないし
酒はダメと言ってるんだから
じゃあまあ酒飲んでタバコ吸いますと
それで酒やめられたところに
自分がすーっとタバコ中毒でいるんですね
なんとなく情けなくなっちゃうんですね
あれ これもちょっと悪いんじゃないと
それで発見して ではこれもやめてみましょうと
で それでやめてみる これで新しい悪が一つなくなったんですね
それで酒もタバコもやめてるんだけど
まあ結構ね 休みの時は友達とぐちゃぐちゃぐちゃぐちゃ世間話をしたり遊んだりして
それで仕事に間に合わなかったり
もう夜もう睡眠不足になったりとかね
なんか考えてみれば なんだか自分の人生が落ち着かないんですね
あれ 何か私 悪いことをやってるんですかと
あら 私はなんか友達とふざける時間がちょっと長すぎ
これが 1 日 1 時間にするそうと
今は時間は決まってなくて
調子に乗ったらもう徹夜までやっちゃうというね
これちゃんと 1 時間で切る
相当すごい成長でしょ
あれ 悪やめたんです それまた時間経っちゃうと
毎日 1 時間っていうのはなんか情けないと
じゃあ週 2回にするぞとかね
そんな感じで まず自分が知ってる範囲で悪をやめるんです
それ真面目にやってみると
あら いまだ発見しなかった自分の生き方について悪いもの
自分の幸福を壊すもの
一つずつ一つずつ見えてくるんですね
だから悪の多い多いもの見えてくるんですね
複数でそれが あ これがで足が引っ張られてるんだと
これが邪魔だと それやめちゃうと次の邪魔なものが見えてくるんですね
この悪さの多い順で見えてくるんです
悪さって ても悪結果が追い込んで
それで最終的にまた本人は忙しくて時間がなくてとかね
結構成長していて それでも忙しくてもう時間がなくてとかね
落ち着きがない なんか落ち着きがないなとかね
これが悪いと 私は落ち着きがないことが私の悪だと
じゃあ落ち着こうと だけど
なんで落ち着かんかなと
それで余計な妄想をしていることを発見するでしょ
ではそこをやめましょうと
考えるならば 大事なことを考えて
それできれいさっぱり終了するぞという風になってくると
相当成長しますね そういうことで
一切悪を起こさないっていうのはね
至って簡単に見えるが
ものすごいしっかりしたシステムなんです
悪を起こすなかれと 一切の悪を起こさないことというのは
異同ではないんです そこで宗教だったら悪を起こすなかれ
人を殺すなかれ 盗むなかれと
これがブッダがそういうふうに言わない
仏教徒になって誤解を受けた時は
それでも殺すなかれではないんです
殺さない戒めを私が守ります
なんです なんか怪しいでしょ
悪を起こす 犯さなかれ
犯すなかれ 一切悪を起こすないこと
同じだと感じるでしょ
同じじゃないんです 悪を起こすなかれっていうのは
ただの言葉なんですよ
実行できないんですよ
どうやってそれ実践しますかね
だから言葉の意味知らないでいい加減に言ってるんです
仏教以外の宗教は この悪を起こすなかれという態度で言ってるんです
お釈迦様はしないこと
それすごく優しいんですし
実践的なんです しないことだったら
まあじゃあ私が自分でこれ
これだけしないことにしましょうと
それで気持ちいいんですよ
悪を起こすなかれと言ったら
いろんな人から世の中に悪って何ですかと聞くでしょ
そうするともう自分には実行できないんですよ
これは間隔だあれ間隔だ
自分毎日やっていることまで言っちゃうとね
これ実行できないんですね
そういうことだから 私は余計なことなんですけど
お釈迦様がおっしゃっているサッブパーパスアカラナンという言葉は
一切の悪を起こさないこと
頑張ってという意味なんですね
お前罪を犯ったんではないかということないんです
そういう訴えがないんです
じゃあ頑張って それから 1週間経ったら
あんたどこまで頑張ったの？って言ったら
私は 1週間でやっと酒だけ半分減らしてみましたよと
でもまだ飲んでるんだよと
ああ なかなかいいんじゃないっていう
褒めてくれるんです あ
そう あんた酒半分減らしたんですかね
ああ いいんじゃない もっと頑張ってということになるんです
例えば宗教で飲むなかれとあったならば
あの人はどうなるんですか？お前まだだらしないでしょうにと
半分やめたってもやめてないだろうと
罪を犯しているだろうというふうに非難を受ける羽目になるんです
人を慈しみで優しく育てていないんです
人を非難しているんです
非難されると 我々は委縮して成長しないんです
だから仏教の世界は人の気持ちを委縮させません
で あんた守っているのかと聞いたら
本人の解説で 本人が理解した範囲で守ったら
もうよし 頑張ってますね
あんたはと褒めてあげるんです
褒めちゃうと さらに調子に乗りやがっちゃって
もっと頑張るということになるんです
だから そういう風に説かれているんだから
これは完全に説かれているんですよ
はい 次の行は禅に至ること
クサラッサウパサンパダ
そこでこの単語を選ぶときも精密なんです
善を行うことと言ってないんです
至ることなんです なんか余計にややこしいんですね
考えてみれば 善を行ないなさいといえばわかりやすいでしょ
でもあれダメなんです
完全に語ったことにならないんです
世の中は誰も悟ってないんだから
他の宗教の方々もね 間違った言葉使ってます
これは小学者の言葉なんです
だから微妙にくさらす
ウパサンパダ ウパサンパダというのはチェーン
英語で言えばビカム 訳すれば軽い
訳すればジェストライドトゥビーグッド
ドゥーグッドではないんです
ジェストライドトゥビーグッド
これで皆さんはドゥーグッドしないとどうやってビーグッドになるのかと
それは自分で判断しなさい
それは自分の問題ですと
悟ったいというのはビーグッドなんです
チェイングッドネス チューグッドネスなんです
まあ英語になってくるといろんな単語で言えますけどね
まあやめます 人は徐々に善に達していく
徐々に善に達していく
例えば自分の子供はかなりやんちゃで
言うことを聞かない これでギャーギャーギャーギャー言ってるでしょ
それは親として悪いことをやっている気持ちがないでしょう
しかし ビーグッド 良い人間にならなくちゃと思っちゃうと
自分がね ギャーギャーと言うんだけど
自分自身でも結構いら立って
ヒステリーになっちゃって怒ってるでしょ
そうするとギャーギャー言うことをやめるんではなくて
そうするとドゥーグッドでしょ
子供叱ることやめましたと
これはドゥーグッドになっちゃうんだから
それではなくて ビーグッド
もっと落ち着きましょうよと
こんなカンカン怒らないことにしますと
これがビーグッド世界なんですね
で 前より怒らないで 前より興奮しないで
前よりヒステリーを起こさないでよ
これやってると子供側も昨日よりは母親の言葉がなんとなく優しいとわかるんです
これでまた 2日 3日だったら
やっぱりもうちょっと先
なぜならば 優しい心で言うと聞いてくれるんですよ
面白いことに それでもうちょっと落ち着いた方がいいと
もうちょっと怒らない方がいいと
それでどんどん自分がビーグッドになっていくんですね
それで最後に やっぱり子供を育てる
子供っていうのは愛情で慈しみで育てなくちゃあかんですよ
私はなんで怒るんですか？と
我が子に対して怒ることをやめちゃう
やめて 自分の子供に対して慈しみが生まれてくる
怒りやめた途端 そうすると怒ることになる
全くなくなっちゃって
微笑みが入っちゃって
あのね 君がそんなことをやったら大変だよ
やらん方がいいんじゃない？っていう感じになるんです
あ 何やってるか あれか
もう消えてるんです そうするともう思い切ってるでしょ
そういう風に ドゥーグッドっていうのは完全なこと
悪い言葉ではないんだけど
完全な言葉ではないんです
ビーグッドなんです これ
ビーグッドになっていくと
自動的にドゥーグッドになっているんです
ドゥーグッドに頑張る必要はないんです
ビーグッドになったら
もう自分がやってることは全部良いことなんです
そういう風に考えれば見事でしょう
この言葉の使い方 完璧
心理学的でしょ それからしっかりと実行できるでしょ
全然嫌な宗教でもないし
信仰を強引に押し付けることもないし
理性があったら誰だってその通りだとわかるはずなんです
コモンセンスさえあれば
はい それで だから善に至ること
至るのは自分ですからね
ウパサンパダーっていうのは
自分が何かの状態に達することなんです
だからドゥーグッドじゃないんです
はい これで 3 行目 最後の行に入ります
サチッタパリヨーダパナン
ローマ字のCはパーリ語を発音する時はチャと発音するんです
オーはいつでも伸ばすんです
オーとエーは伸ばすんです
ほか 伸ばすべき母音の場合は
上にちょっと棒を引いておくんです
日本語と違って伸ばす伸ばすまいかということによって意味が変わっちゃうんです
サチッタっていうのは
自分の心清らかにすること
これで智慧が現れているんです
悪を犯さないことと 善良い人間になることに頑張っちゃうと
なんで私がこんな変な生き方したのかとも見えてくるんですね
これ 心に問題があったんです
心に汚れがあって 悪を犯していたんです
心に汚れがあって 善になれなかったんです
結局は心清らかだったらいいでしょうにと
そうすると 表向きだったらもう悪いこともしていないし
良い善に達しているし
まだ完全にはなってないんですね
そこで自分の心の中で生まれてくるいろいろ汚れを見て
そこないようにするんです
それはそんなに難しくないんですね
自分の心に何か嫉妬が生まれたら
じゃあ出て行ってとね
なんか落ち込んだら もうもういいや
落ち込んでいる場合じゃないとすぐ変えられますでしょ
興奮が生まれる 興奮しちゃってまずい
じゃあ興奮 さよなら 出て行ってとか
その都度その都度汚れを蹴っ飛ばすことできます
それも難しいことじゃないんです
小さいところから始まるんです
そこで汚れが落としちゃうと
すぐ洗って ふっと拭いて洗ってする
これでどんどん微妙な汚れまで見えてきて
完全に心が清らかになるんです
それで仏道終了です もう解脱に達しているんです
これ以上言うことはないんです
3 行で完全に悟りに達する道も教えています
これは完全に語られていて
実行できるように語られてあって
人を裁くことはまるっきりなくて
人を褒めてあげるんです
応援しているんです 助けているんです
協力しているんです 頑張っていると
そういうことで 出家衆に基づいてこの三行を語ったんです
これがブッダヌササーサナ
はい 四行で仏道をすべて語られています
はい 今日のテーマはあの
実践の仕方に入りました
もうちょっとあの あの
これから深い ちょっと深いところに入りますけど
次の偈に入らなくちゃいけないだからね
まあそれでちょっと脱線して別の話をします
この間 日本の方々と一緒にカンボジア
ラオスとかね ちょっと旅行に行きましたけど
私は他のテーラワーダ仏教の国々の状況を知りたいという気持ちがありましたけど
結局は日本のグループツアーっていうのはね
犬の散歩ですからね 鎖でつなげてね
連れて行くところに行って
自分には楽しかろうとかなかろうが関係なく元に戻らなくちゃあかんだからね
そうやって 散歩に連れて行かれてね
それでも犬ではね 犬は頑張ります
自分に楽しいことをやろうと
飼い主はやらせないんですね
で カンボジアのある有名なお寺がありましてね
結構大きいお寺でね カンボジアというのは仏教はこのポル・ポト政権が自滅させたんですね
完璧にお寺をすべて壊して
何十万もお坊さんたちを殺したり
減速させたりして 経典をすべて燃やして仏教はにしちゃったんです
それでも平和を取り戻した瞬間で
仏教がガッと現れたんです
そこでまあ ゼロになった仏教はどうやって復活しているのかっていうところがね
よく調べたところである
お坊さんがね あのグループのほとんどみんな若いお坊さんたちばっかしですね
カンボジアでもタイに行ったり
いろんなところに行って勉強して
さっさと新しい一人だけちょこっと年上のお坊さんがいたんですけど
それでも私より年上じゃないんで
歳は上かもしれませんだけどね
坊さんとしてはね で その人はフランスで勉強した人で
英語はようわからない英語なんですけど
時間かかるんですね 喋る時は
うん 自分が何をやっているのかということで
すっごく時間かけて自慢げに言うのは
まずホールに入る前に看板を見せたんですね
看板を見せて この看板に何書いてるのかというと
このサッバパーパッサカラなんていう偈なんですね
偈を書いて カンボジアのケムル号と
それからね 日本語訳もあってね
英訳も英語訳もあってね
すごく胸があって これよく見てくださいと
私見てなんだいと それで日本のグループのみんな暗記してるんだからね
なんだいと よくピンとこないんですね
仏教はもうちょっとしっかり頑張ってほしいでしょうにと
それで喋ってる時でも
自分がやっている活動を通して
このこれをもう結構よく印刷して
すべての学校に何十万も印刷して配ってるんだと
いろんな人にその紙を渡してるんだと
だからそれもお坊さんとしては結構お金もかかる作業でしょう
そのお坊さんが必死必死でそれやってるんですね
そこでさらにその状況を勉強したところでわかったんですね
彼らの指導者であったお坊さんがいて
ずいぶんシンプルに説法してカンボジアを作ってくれたんですね
偉大なる人で その人はもうものすごい偉い人でね
もう冗談じゃないんです
すごい学者で しかし喋っていることは小学生1年生にもわかる
一つも難しいことを喋ったことはないんです
はい そのお坊さんの導きだなと
なぜかというと それで私は後でわかったんですね
あ この芸だけでカンボジア人に十分やと
だからカンボジア人がみんな落ち着いてるんですね
みんな優しい 偉い ややこしい仏教とか知らない
知らないんだけど 立派な人間ですね
どういうやり方かで 何かやりたければ自分に問うんですね
これいいこと悪いこと
それだけ 例えば何かやってもらって
あんたのいくら欲しいですかと聞いたら
本人がこの人はいくらでも金くれるんだから
じゃあ 10ドルぐらいで十分なんです
じゃあ 25ドル要求しますと
20ドルちょうだいと言いたくなるでしょ
言ったらこれいいこと？悪いこと
やっぱり ちょっと知らない人
弱い人から金取り上げることをあげることになるんだからやめて
10ドル十分ですと するとあげる人も 10ドルよく仕事しまったからね
一生懸命 じゃあ 15ドル
じゃあ 25あげましょうということになるんです
だからただそれだけ いつでも何かやろうとすると
これいいこと 悪いこと
それだけで直りますよ
人間が 難しいこといらん
哲学は要りません ただいつでも
これいいこと 悪いこと
自分に聞くだけ いとも簡単にすごい立派な人間になるんです
性格は 自分が何の戒律も
この生き方 この生き方とかね
100ぐらい項目を紙に書いて
壁にぶら下がったりとかね
何もないんです  1これ
2これ  3これとかね 何もなく
自由に 自由に動き回って
しかし いつでも何かやろうとすると
いいこと 悪いことと 人と喋りたくなったら
これ言っていいこと悪いことと聞けば自分に
だからそこで私は勉強にしてなったのは
なるほど カンボジアの人々が仏教はゼロの状態に破滅になったのに
このシンプルな教えでガーンと復活したんです
元の状態というよりも
国民にはもう欠かせない
国民を守る巨大な生き方までになるまでと成長しちゃったんです
すごい簡単に すごく早く
はい 私たちの行為っていうのは
信仰を言って 3つありますね
体って信っていうのは体でやること
口っていうのは言葉でしゃべること
言ってのは考えることですね
行為  3つですよ だから
まず我々の体の中で何かやりたいな
何か喋りたいな 何か考えたいなという衝動が生まれるんです
皆様には考えたい衝動はわからないかもしれません
まず何かやりたくなるでしょ
その時の衝動をチェックしてください
それから何か喋りたくなるでしょ
その時 喋りたくなったエネルギーを感じてください
それができたら 考えたくなった衝動も見えてくるんです
はい そこは次 このサンカーラが善悪になるんです
衝動にサンカーラーと言うんです
その時 これは善 それとも悪？と自分に聞いてみる
それだけ 終わり すべての生き方が善になってしまうんです
粗い行為 行為から始めますが
能力が上がると細かい行為まで管理できるようになります
悪と善の意欲を起こす衝動を発見してそれを足す
最後 悪を起こしたい衝動
善を起こしたい衝動も足すんです
それが悟りなんです 皆様
ちょっと善を起こすと衝動を足してどうかなと思うかもしれませんだけど
悟りの境地では善も悪も何もないんです
これは比較的に対照的に生まれる単語ですよ
だから善行と判断するために
悪とはなんぞやと基礎的にないと出てこない
これは悪やと判断するために
善とはなんぞやというあれが必要なんですね
相対的なんですね それでこの衝動を見つけた人が
衝動だけ善になったり
悪になったりする 邪悪しや
この衝動はと そこでなんとかなるんですね
そこはなんとかなったら関与を減らす
はい これは実践の仕方なんです
はい そこで今日のテーマに入ってみましょう
何かしら一時間もなってしまいました
この次の偈はカンティー・パラマン・タポーティティッカー・ニッバーナ・パラマン・ワダンティ・ブッダ・ナニ・パッバジト・パルーパ・ガーティ・サマノ・ホーティ・パラム・ビヒタヤンと
皆様はもう手元にテキスト
まあ皆様の家であるんだから
この言葉二つだけ説明して終了します
はい これでお釈迦様が第一の偈で理論的に悪を起こさないこと
善に達すること 自ら心を清らかにすることというふうに言っておきました
これ 実践の仕方も書きました
私は説明しました 次にお釈迦様が実践の仕方教えてあげているんです
で この百八十三偈なんですね
論理的に仏道を説かれました
百八十四はダンマパダのね
実践 やってみることを推薦するんです
心を清らかにする道こそは修行です
だから修行っていうのは心清らかにすることなんです
滝行でも断食行でもあれでもなんでもないんです
読経することでも 大目録となえることでも
念仏となえることでもなんでもないんです
心を清らかにすることです
そんなのはやってもやらなくてもどうでもいいんです
自分の心を清らかに保つ
それで完璧な修行者なんです
ここでタポ カンティーパラマンタポ
まあ三四語になってくるタパスですね
という単語を使います
苦行を意味する場合もタパスという語を使われた
そこでインド文化では宗教って派手で特別にいろんなもうだらしないことをやってますよ
今も裸でいたり ナーガサードゥというグループがいるので
インターネットでチェックしてください
ものすごく褒めも褒められたり讃えられますけど
もう世界じゅうだらしないんですよ
汚いものを食べるわ 裸でいるわ
もう体いじめるわ きりがないんで
やることは 体は絶対洗わないわ
なんでそんなことをやるのかと言ったって
ヒンドゥ教でもそんなことをやってくださいとどこにも書いてないんだけど
あのアホどもたちがやってるんです
ジャイナ教は苦行は推薦してましたけど
ジャイナ教は苦行推薦してる
ジャイナ教は寺はすごい綺麗なんです
埃一つもなく それで在家の人々はものすごい綺麗な白い服を着ているんです
苦行する宗教がかっこよく品格よくいるのに
お釈迦様の時代で ジャイナの人々も裸でいましたけど
今も隠れたところでは裸でいますけど
ジャイナ教のサードゥを裸のサードゥ見たっても
そんなに気持ち悪くならないんです
これが何かと とにかく体いじめることを体に釘を打ったり
釘でぶら下がってもらったり
火の上で歩いたり もう断食したり
あるいは猿行やったり
インドのハヌマンという神様がいてね
神様っていうのは 3億何匹もいますから
あの インド人口一人当たり神様は二人ぐらいいるんです
まあで その中でハヌマンという猿なんですね
神に仕立てて それでハヌマン神様を信仰する修行者が体を裸にして
体に灰を塗って 猿のようにいろいろ模様もつけて
喋れないんです 猿は喋れませんだからね
これでなんとかなんとか言うんです
質問したら それと隣の人が座っていて
今神様はこういう言葉を言いましたと通訳するんです
これは知識人であるインド人は信じるんです
インド人は基本的に知識人なんです
宗教になってくるとアホになるんです
だから宗教っていうのはどんな人もアホにするんですよ
そういうことで このタパスという苦行ということがもう流行っていたんですね
そこでお釈迦様が理性の言葉で心を清らかにすることがタパスであると
あんなだらしないものを一言葉で全部却下
制服を着ても 別に派手にブランドの服
品物で身飾っていたっても
それは関係ないんだと
心を清らかにしなさいと
贅沢に食べてもね それではなくて
心を清らかにすることやと
そこで断食したんだからといって
あんたの心はどうですかと
ある業者がお釈迦様に会ったか
お釈迦様はその業者のところに行ったかどうかと
その業者がえらい厳しい苦行をしているんですね
もう修行を始めたその日から何年も体洗ってない
現代のナゲサードゥと似ているんです
体もう想像できないんですよ
我々こんな１０年体洗った人がいない
最低１年も体洗ってない人っていうのは見たことないでしょう
まあ見ないでください
そんなにいいものでもないんです
で 髪の毛はこうやって結んでいるんですね
ターバンみたいな感じでね
ジャターと言うんですね
ターバンといえば髪 布を使いますけど
布は使わないで髪だけ結んで置いておくんです
髪は洗わないんだからね
シラミはいたいた放題
まあゴキブリもいるでしょうね
もしかすると 他の虫たちもね
それからこの 体の汚れがね
栄養にして それからもう肉もどんどん出てきて
もうどうしようもない状態なんです
近寄れないんです その上
この人が 裸ではなかったんです
何か着ていたんです 鹿の革
皆様着ているレザーウェアとは違います
皆様着る革製品っていうのは
もういろんな工程経て経て柔らかくして
もう大変ですよ あれでも濡れたらどうなるんですかね
濡れたまんまでおいてください
どうなるのかと 腐っちゃいますよ
カビが生えてきて そんなものじゃなくて
剥がし取られた ちょこっと干したその鹿の革なんですね
これで体洗わない この人が体に鹿の革をつけておくと
もう自分の顔と鹿の革が一緒になっちゃうでしょ
よく生きていたことを私は不思議に思いますけどね
でもこれはやっぱり命っていうのはえらい頑丈で
細菌が入れば入るほど免疫力が上がるんですよ
でお釈迦様がその人を見て
キンテージャターヒドゥンメーダ
お前のこの頭の上でね
すごい長い間ね もうあれ結びをつけちゃってね
これ威張ってますけどね
何やこれやと キンテーアジナサーテカ
お前のこの鹿の革 それって何やと
アッバンタランセテーガハナン
お前の心の中 ものすごく汚いんだよと
叱っちゃった 全然もうゴミ扱い
お釈迦様はお釈迦様は体がゴミだから言ったんじゃないんです
お前 体もゴミだらけにしていても
何の意味もないでしょうにと
だって心がゴミだらけだから
バーヘランパリマッジス
お前は外だけ何とかしようと思っているんだと
だから外を何とかする必要はないんです
外は関係ないんです 心清らかにしようと
そういうことで タパス
本当の修行は心清らかにすることです
そこで修行の頭は何でしたかと
カンティーとティティッカです
はい 心清らかにしたいでしょ
修行ですね ではまず何ですかね
修行の頭はカンティーとティティッカなんです
忍耐と堪忍なんです 今日はそれを説明します
これは道義語です 仏教用語はカンティーです
忍耐だけなんです 時々意味を強調するためにティティッカとペアにするんです
カンティーの意味はサンティ
サンスクリット語でシャーンティという
語もあります 皆様 ヨガとか馴染みがあるでしょ？ヨガやってる人でシャンティシャンティって言うでしょ
あれは安穏 安穏 平和 平和って意味で使ってますね
同じこと 言葉は同じです
仏教は誰よりも先にカンティーという言葉を使っていたんです
はい 成長する道 ハードルを乗り越えることは成長の道です
ちょっと頭きれいにして聞いてください
何かダブンと変わります
成長するって何ですか？と
仏教は成長 成長というのは悟りにまで行ってくださいと
解脱にまで行ってくださいとね
なんです この成長の道とは
ハードルを乗り越えることなんです
そこをよく理解してください
でなきゃどうにもならないんです
ハードルって何ですかね
楽を期待する人はそのままです
例えば子供が遊ぶこと
楽でしょ 遊んで遊んで
お母さん作ったご飯食べて
疲れたら寝る 一番楽な生き方なんです
はい その子は楽を目指したらそのまんまでしょ
猿で人生終わっちゃうんです
私たちはどうも楽を探し求めているでしょ
だから人類はだらしないんですよ
だからこの様なんです
何も向いていない 楽を目指しているんだから
これすごい勘違いなんです
いつでも子供のことを覚えてください
皆さんは知ってるでしょ
子供にとって幸せは遊ぶことと甘いものを食うことと寝ることでしょ
これ 3つは そこそこやってもらわないとね
成長はないんです そこで子供は成長したっていうことは
計算すると遊ぶを減らしたんですよ
それで甘いものも 嫌々ででも
お母さんが怖いんだからという理由であっても
減らしていくと体も成長するでしょ
疲れたら寝るんじゃなくて
怖いお母さんそばにいるんだから
やっぱり宿題も頑張ってやってから寝るとかね
そこでちょこっと苦労したんですよ
そういう風にちょこちょことハードルがあって
そこを乗り越える そこを乗り越える
そこで成長している これは法則ですよ
どうにもならん 例えば
しっかり生きられるのは
皆様が飼っている猫ですか？野生の猫ですかね
野生の猫にはハードルが多いんです
だからしっかりして生きてるんです
飼ってる犬 猫はどうにもなっちゃうんです
もうもう ぶよんぶよんと太って
どうにもならんですね
少々でも成長したいと思うなら
そこに何かしらハードルがあります
それでこのハードルっていうのは
自分が目指した成長にぴったし合ってるハードルなんです
例えば勉強したいと思ったら眠くなるんですね
そうすると この眠気さえなければ勉強できたのにとか文句言っちゃうでしょ
あるいは負けちゃって
今はちょっと寝て後で勉強しますと
それで寝て後で勉強するとまた眠くなるんです
そこでその人にそれがハードルなんです
まあ例えば何かね 選抜試験があるとしますね
いく何人か選ばれて 何人かダメになるという
そこでハードル 2つがあるんですね
例えば 5人しか選べないんだったら
試験は 100人受けと受けるとするならば
自分が 95人と戦わなくちゃあかんでしょ
95人の能力を乗り越えなくちゃあかんでしょ
それで勉強もしなくちゃ
ハードル2つが現れてくるんです
だから達したいという決めたものに対して
それなりのハードルがついていて
そこを破ったら成功しているんです
95人より能力を発揮したら
もう合格 終わり それは超えたら成長です
私たちにどこまでハードルに立ち向かうことができるのでしょうか？と個人で聞いてみてください
あんたはどんなところで腰を上げるんですかと
どんな瞬間で一歩前へ巻くんですかと
そこでストップです だから人はどこまで成長できるかというと
どこで腰を抜かしちゃったところまでなんです
ああ もう嫌になっちゃった
もうこれぐらいだと思ったところで
成長が終わり だからそれも人間の真理を見事に語っていると思いますよ
人間はどこまで成長できるのかという疑問に
またどこで腰を上げるのかということなんです
ハードルに対して 問題に対して
あらゆるトラブルに対して
はい またテーマを変えて生きることが同じことなんです
あの仕事を成功するとかね
勉学を成功するとか そんな小さな話ではなくて
全体的に生まれてから死ぬまでに生きることなんですかね
これもハードルを乗り越えることなんです
できなかった時 死にます
毎秒 毎分 毎時 毎日 何かの障害に当たって乗り越えることは生きることでもあります
毎秒 毎分 毎時 もう何かあるんです
で 乗り越えていくんです
だって寒くなったり 暖かくなったりね
体が痛くなったり いろいろあるでしょうに
息が苦しくなったり 食欲がなくなったり
食べ過ぎになったりして
いろいろ いつでもハードルがあるんです
私はだいたい呼吸まで入れちゃうんですよ
呼吸することもハードルなんです
やらなかったら死にます
呼吸しなかったらすごい苦しいんです
だからずっと苦しみがあって
私たちには挑戦し あんた苦しみと対応するか死ぬか
対応するか死ぬかなんです
それで体中苦しみが れてくるんだから呼吸するんです
それで終わったかというと終わってないんです
苦しみが消えてないんです
また呼吸しなくちゃいけない
それで体が疲れるでしょ
肺やらね 時期が来るんですよ
呼吸できないという 昔はその場で死んじゃったんだけど
今は機械に入れて無理やり酸素を入れちゃうでしょ
それでもダメです 無理やり酸素機械でポンプで入れても
肺が受け取れないということになっちゃうんです
壊れだして それで死にます
だから 生きること自体はずっと毎晩
毎秒 毎秒障害があって
そこを乗り越えなくちゃいけない
これ理解してほしい これが現実です
脅してるわけじゃないんです
褒め称えたらインチキ
詐欺 嘘です 汝らは神の子であると褒めてもらって地獄に落ちたければ
大川隆法のところに行ってください
直行地獄に行きます あの頭イカれてる人も自分がブッダの生まれ変わりだと
仏教って何かとわかってるんですかね
あの無知な人は この障害には終わりがありませんね
生きる時出てくる障害にはね
例えば金も必要でしょ
これが終わりがない 終わりないでしょ
それでも物価が高くなるわ
品物は安心かないかわからないわ
日本では経済成長っていうのは物価が上がることだそうですね
私がずっと調べれば 物価が上がって一般人に買えない状態になったら抜群な経済成長です
そういうことだから 私は正直に経済成長しない方が国民は楽じゃないかなと思ったりもします
それは置いておいて 金がいるということも障害なんですね
これ 終わりがないんですね
徐々に障害が高くなる
生きる上では 若い時は仕事をして金儲かってるでしょ
年取ってくると年金だけになって収入がないんだけど
ハードルが高くなっちゃって金がかかるんです
体を維持するために 車椅子が必要になっちゃうし
普通の車で行けなくなっちゃうし
あるいは寝たきりにもなったりするし
ヘルパーを頼まなくちゃ
相当金がかかっちゃう
だから金がない どうしますかね
ハードルが高くなっちゃうんです
若い時から貯金もしたのに
これで乗り越えられなくなって
最後に悔しく死にます
わざわざ悔しくという言葉を入れたのは
わざと入れたんです なぜならば
悔しく死なない方法は仏教を教えますからね
成功して死ぬ方法が教えるんです
はい 俗世間のトラブルについてちょっと考えましょう
日常の諸々の問題に私たちの対応は大事です
対応の仕方によって成功したり失敗したりします
精神的悩み 精神病 人間関係の問題
経済 家族の問題などが起きます
なんで我々に経済問題ある？人間関係の問題ある
仕事のトラブルがある
家族の中でもトラブルがある
友達関係でもいろいろとか
なんでやねん これはと
いたって簡単 答えは 毎日私がぶつかる問題に
私の対応の仕方に何かあったんです
それで問題が起きているんです
例えば精神病ってなんですかね
対応の仕方が間違ったんです
例えば精神的な悩みはどうですかね
精神病をやめて何か落ち込んでいる
なかなか治らない あれ
対応の仕方なんですね
この災害を受けた方 遭遇した方々にしても
PTなんだらかんだらというね
ポスシンドロームなんとかって病気にかかってるでしょ？精神的に
対応が間違っているんです
災害 災害という言葉はおかしいだけで
どんな人間も毎日災害に遭遇しているんです
そこそこ対応しているんです
だからって対応できない場合もあります
それにはあえて災害というだけ
できなかったらできなかったで
悔しい なんで落ち込むんですかね
親戚が亡くなった 家族が亡くなった
大きな災害ですよ 大きな問題ですね
自分にかかってきた 対応はどうすればいいんですかね
いたって簡単 あんたどうする？例えば
ある人のお子さんも子供 3人も亡くなったとしましょう
耐えられない悲しみでしょ
問題にぶつかったんだから
次 自分に聞く じゃあ私はどうする？この問題に対して答えがすぐ出てくるでしょ
あのね 何もできませんと
それだけです すごく失礼に感じるかもしれませんだけど
本当はこれは答えなんです
あんたどうする？私は私の場合
その質問するんですけど
私の人生の中でも もう次から次へとトラブルが起こるんです
その場合どうする？あ
こうすればいい この場合
こうすればいい とそれやるんですね
この場合は放っておく
この場合はどうすることもない
それできれいさっぱり
そういうわけで この対応の仕方によって
例えば家族が亡くなったことに助けてあげることはできませんでしたとかね
私は先に来て家族を高台に連れて行った方がよかったとかね
そんなことを考えればどうなるんですかね
ああすればよかった こうすればよかったとか
一つも実効性がないでしょ
これで自己破壊になるんです
悩み 苦しみに陥るんです
病気になるんです 体動かなくなっちゃう
動かなくなっちゃうんです
仮設住宅でじーっと閉じこもれて
料理も作らない 食欲もない
それでボランティアの方々は心配して
おじいさん何かご飯食べたんですか？と言ったら
食べてない 昨日昨日も食べてないと
大変だ じゃあこれ食べてくださいと
置いたっても これ開けて食べたいって気持ちがなくて
私も死んだ方が よかったとかね
なんで私だけ残った残ったんですか？とかね
すべて完璧無知な質問ばっかり
なんで私だけ お前別に残って残ってないんだよでしょ
答えは これ自然災害だからね
ぶつかった人は死んじゃった
ぶつからなかった人は残っただけの話で
お前特別に特別扱いして残ったわけじゃない
キリスト教はそう言うんだけどね
あんな変なことを だからまあ
私も一緒に死ねばよかった
だったら死になさい 死になさいよと
ハチャメチャなんです
そういうわけで 今わかりやすい皆様にもね
それすごい短い経験だから
その例を出したんです
毎日トラブルが起こる
毎日問題が起こる もっと派手に毎日災害やと思った方が楽じゃない
人生って毎日災害だよと
これで対応する あれ自分に聞く
私はどうすればいいと
人が喧嘩売りに来る 災害でしょ
どうすればいい？うーん
逃げた方がいい じゃあ逃げてください
別にそれで話終わりですよ
それで全て終わりじゃないんですよ
災害はもうもう連続してくるんだからね
逃げたところで そちらで捕まって捕まっちゃったってこともあり得る
逃げたら 逃げたところで本人がそこで見つかっちゃったと
どうすれば 逃げられませんね
じゃあもう対応すると
だから そういう風に生きていた方が理想的でしょ
そこで私が言うのは 精神的な悩み
精神的な病気 それから人間関係
仕事関係 経済関係 家族関係
いかなる問題であっても
あなたは障害に対してどのように対応したかということです
対応があったら問題がなし
対応が間違ったらトラブル
新たなトラブル そこで新たなトラブルも自分が対応すれば治ります
落ち込んだらそれは新たなトラブルです
それに対応すればそれがなくなります
よく覚えてください この後悔して悩むんじゃなくてね
こうすればよかった こうすればよかったっていうことはね
あまりにも無知なんですね
それではなくて 私はどうする？この場合は
そのように聞いてください
どうする？どうすることもできん
そう じゃあやめて で 問題はありませんと
あの どうすることもできないトラブルはトラブルではありません
例えば 両親の誰かが危篤状態に陥っている
歳も 88歳とかね 悲しいでしょ
ちょっと落ち込んじゃうんですね
自分にあんたどうする？どうすると言われたって
もうどうすることもできんね
危篤状態でから喋ったってわからないんだから
では問題はありません
普通にいればいいんです
それは自分に対して関わるべき問題ではありません
じゃあ万が一 意識が戻って自分を探したらという疑いがあったら
そばにいてあげればいいんです
そばにいても話せませんだから本でも読んだり
ゲームでもやったりするんです
それで意識が戻って読んだらどうですかとかね
聞けばいいでしょう で
息を途切ったら引き取ったら亡くなったと
それから自分に関わっている問題が起きているんです
次どうしますか？と それに対応する
すごい楽に生きられる
生きられるはずなんです
トラブルに対応すること
対応の仕方も考えてください
面と向かってぶつかるものもある
ちょっとまわりでちょっと回ってなんとかする方法もある
逃げる場合もある あるいはでっかいトラブルだけど
どうすることもない それはゼロ
トラブルではありません
私たちはトラブルではないものが最大トラブルだと思っちゃうでしょ
例えば 大震災で家族が亡くなったことは
その人にとって最大の問題だと
そういう問題ないんです
本当は それ 人間の問題の取り方の勘違いなんです
親が死ぬこと 病気になって自分の子供が死ぬこととか
人生のトラブルじゃないんです
それは だってどうすることもできないでしょ
子供が病気にかかって病院にいる間は
両親の責任ですね 看病すること
その時は自分の問題 対応する
それでも子供は息を引き取ってしまっちゃう
それから問題ではありません
だってどうすることもできんだから
できる時は頑張ったんだから
できる時はハチャメチャ頑張りました
今は誰もできません それだったら
まあ文化に従って それなりに何とかして
楽にいればいいんです
普通のニュースだけにすればいいんです
ああ 私にも子供が 3人いたんだけどね
一人は亡くなりましたね
10歳で そんな感じで言ったらいいんです
どういうことで まあなんか珍しい病気にかかってね
あの子は本当は 1  2年もすごい苦しみましたねとかね
その時は私もすごいショックで苦しんだんだよ
その時はとかね ニュースだけ
ああ 悲しいとかね それダメなんですね
怒り これは恨み 嫉妬 落ち込みなどで問題が悪化することもあります
そういうさらに心汚れていると
こういう怒り 欲も入ります
怒り 欲 恨み 嫉妬 憎しみ
落ち込み 舞い上がり 高慢
傲慢 卑下慢 こういう感情が割り込んじゃうと対応が間違っちゃうんです
あの 例えば よく儲かる株を買ったりするでしょ
で 奥さんは何もする必要ない
ここでサインしてお金を送金すれば十分です
もう利益はすぐ再来週 1週間でも入りますよと
こんな楽な話って言ってサインして金あげる
通帳を渡す 判子と一緒に
それから警察に走ったってもね
もう後の祭り 犯人を見つかったっても
金だけは返ってこないんでしょ
それはもう欲でトラブっちゃったんです
そこで会社でも学校でも我々は
競争世界だから 仲間同士でもちょっと競争しなくちゃいけないという悲しい状況があるんですよ
会社でも同僚の間で微妙な隠れた競争があるんですね
だって誰だって昇進したいんだから
昇格したいんだから みんな菩薩じゃないんだからね
どうぞあなた昇格してくださいと
そんなこと言っちゃったら
自分家に帰っちゃったら奥さんに殺されますからね
ですから 我々はやっぱり否応なしに仲間同士でも競争する社会で生きているんですよ
これなくせないんですよ
これが私に対する一つの障害なんです
トラブルなんです 問題です
対応しなくちゃいかん
そこで怒りで仲間を憎んだりして
嫉妬したりしちゃうと
アウト 負ける 裏で何か足を引っ張ってやろうかなと思っちゃうと
それこそ良くない バレたら終わり
全部 裏で足を引っ張ろうとすることもね
怒りでしょ 憎しみでしょ
そういうことで対応をしようと思っても
心に欲 怒り 嫉妬 憎しみ
恨みなどがあると あなたの対応が間違えますと
間違ったらひどい目に遭います
新たな苦しみ 新たな問題が起こるんです
問題一つにぶつかった人が対応を間違ったら
問題が 1万ぐらいになるんです
かなり増えます 細菌みたいな感じで
そういうことで 正しい生き方っていうものはあるんですね
必ず負ける道を選ぶ必要はありません
我々は負ける道を選ぶんですね
問題 ハードル 障害などは自然法則です
全然気にしないでください
問題あることが法則です
それ乗り越えたことが成長です
そればかりではありません
協力的な原因もあります
だから問題ばっかりだったら妙激できないでしょ
ただ 会社の同僚はみんな自分を落として昇格したいと思っているんだったら
自分にとってはもう歯が立たないんでしょう
どうにもならん そうじゃないんです
協力的な原因もあります
例えば 会社の同僚はみんな自分に対して恨み
嫉妬 憎しみで足を引っ張ろうとする
しかし 自分が仕事の能力はあるんです
誰よりもしっかり仕事をする
失敗はなし これ自分の味方になるんです
それ出せばトランプカードとして自分の上の人に
あのね 誰選んだってもいいんですよと
しかし あなたは仕事を能力で選ぶならば
私のほうが仕事の能力ありますよと
今までこれぐらいやって失敗したことはないんだよと
はい さようならと 選べますよ
例えば 子供は学校でことこといじめられていじめたりする
それでも子供はもうあまり気にしない
でも悲しいし 家に帰ると優しいお母さんがいる
お父さんもいる お父さんもね
どうだい お前 今日やられちゃったんですかねとかね
これ男らしく頑張ったなとかね
聞いちゃうと あ 味方もいるんだよと
というわけで 我々には味方もいるんですよ
そこで私たちは協力を得ること
それから良い原因を揃うこともしなくちゃあかん
これもハードルなんですよ
例えば 学校で 3人の子供にいじめられる
それで他の子供たちがあんまりそこは賛成しません
それでこの子供があら
この連中を味方に回しちゃえば俺の勝ちやと
あの 3人を抑えることはできるぞとわかっちゃえばどうですかね
そこでそう簡単に味方にはなってくれませんよ
いじめ反対かもしれませんだけど
それでちょこちょこっと仲良くしてあげて
なんか何とか手伝ったりもしてあげて
そこで味方を増やす そう
味方を増やすことも自分にとってのハードルなんです
だから ハードルとは攻撃的で自分を潰すハードルだけではなくて
自分に協力してくれる原因もあるんだけど
そこは自分の方向へ回してもらわなくちゃあかんね
それもちょっと頑張らなくちゃあかんですね
完全知者であるブッダのアドバイスに従う
だからお釈迦様のアドバイスを聞けば解決します
それは悪をやめて善を行う道を選びます
まず俗世間で成功します
いたって簡単です まあとにかく私は悪をやめて善を行う
行うと書いちゃったんですけど
本当は善になる道なんですね
善になる道を選んじゃうと
結構敵的なハードルが減っていく
味方的なものがどんどん増えていく
私はそこまで仏教を知らなかったアホな時
子供頃も何かしらわからないんだけど
このやり方やっていたんです
自慢できない その時わかっていなかったんです
ブッダのこの教えは こんな深く
でも 自分の子供頃の学生頃の生き方を見ると
私は一つも悪いことをしなかったんです
先生たちはダメということは裏ででもやらない
やりなさいということは必ずやる
そこで教室の仲間にいつでも助けてあげる
で だからそういうやり方だから
どうせ勉強できるようになるでしょ
勉強できるようになっちゃ
あいつらふざけているんだから
勉強できなくなったりして
先生に叱られる羽目になったりする
それで私はさっさとやって
これはこういうこと これはこういうこと
これはこういうことやと教えてあげたりする
そこでいじめる体力のある友達もいたんですよ
でもその友達たちはね
お前こっち来いとかね
可愛がってくれるんです
時々学校でいろいろ体力必要ないろんな仕事をさせるんですね
何か作りなさいとか そこで木材用の小切手切ったり
釘を打ったりとか あれやこれや重いものを運んだりとかね
私はそれほどできないわけないんだけど
もうそれは他の友達と見ると体力がないんですね
ものすごい体力の連中がいるんですからね
あの人々をドンと出ていけて
貸して貸してこれとかね
ちょっと待ってとか ドンドンドンドンってやっちゃって
はい どうですかねとか
OK と そこできめ細かい作業になってくると
私がやって あの人のこともやってあげたりする
だからうまくいくんです
それはこの道だなと 悪いことをしない
隠れてでもしない だから隠すものは何も
良いことだったら何の躊躇もなくさっさとやる
はい そういうことで このブッダの教えを実行してみれば
一 この世で成功する それで毎日善になっているんだから
良い人間になっているんだから
80歳で死ぬ時になっちゃうと
修行は 30歳で始めても 50年間頑張って良い人間になっているんです
悔しくはないんです 生まれた人間が死んでいるわけじゃないんです
犬猫みたいにあっけなく死ぬわけじゃないんです
みんなに嫌われて死ぬわけじゃないんです
すごい立派な人格者で死ぬんです
先は心配する必要はないんです
心を清らかにすることを目指します
それでどんどん社会の仕事を減っていくと
その分心を清らかにすることに頑張る
退職したら心の世界に入り込む
体が弱くなったら まあ体はいい
心を清らかにしろと 心は病気になりませんし
脳出血も起こしませんしね
糖尿病にもかかりませんだからね
だからあれは肉体のことで
心を清らかにすることは椅子だってできます
だから たとえ寝たきりになっちゃっても
心を清らかにするチャンスだけは残っている
そうするといいんじゃないかなと思います
はい 修行の仏道は解脱を目指すんだからね
高度な目的を目指すと
ハードルも高度になります
当たり前ね このハードルに対応できる力はカンティ忍耐です
そこでカンティが入ります
今までも入ったんだけど
説明わざとしなかったんです
ずっと忍耐があったんです
で 言わなかったんです
ここから入れます じゃあ解脱を目指そうという極限の高いハードルを作る
そうすると高い目標を作る
そうするとハードルも合わせて高くなっちゃうんです
そこで助けになるのはカンティ忍耐なんです
忍耐がある人は簡単に諦めません
忍耐っていうのは諦めません
だってハードルは当たり前だから
ハードルが高い やめたって言ったらもうないで何もないでしょ
はい 目的は正しければ
決していかなる場合でも諦めてはいけません
時々は諦めることも一緒ですよ
場合によって 例えば もう誰かが癌になったとする
治療も一生懸命治療するんだけど
まあやっぱり ダメだとわかったら
まあ癌を治してもらうっていうことは諦めるしかないんですね
諦めて他に何かあるのかいと考えるだけ
人は誰だって死にますから
それはもう諦めるしかないんですね
しかし 目的が正しければどうしますかね
そこで問題は 私たち立てる目的って本当に正しいかということなんですね
こんなもう腐った頭で考えるものだから
だからブッダが教えた目的に出てください
心を清らかにする これはもう間違いなし
完全に善たる目的なんです
それはお釈迦様は決して諦めてはあかんやと
心を清らかにするということは
何があってもやるぞという風に決めてほしい
これが忍耐というんです
だってハードルだから
何から何まで この忍耐という言葉を使ったのは
道がハードルだからなんです
また同じタイトル 忍耐は修行の頭
問題から逃げないで解決する力がないと何も得られません
したがって 忍耐 また一つ忍耐があってこそ修行です
いや 忍耐こそが修行です
これは無知な忍耐ではありません
理性に基づいた状況を把握できる
判断能力がある 希望が叶える忍耐です
心を清らかにするっていうことになる
そうすると いろんなトラブルが消えるわけじゃないだろうと
これ無理だろうという問題ばっかり出てくるんです
それで逃げないで対応していく
だからといって バカみたく無批判でただがむしゃら頑張るっていうことは仏教でダメなんです
どのようにうまくいくのかと
いろいろ理性で考えて
状況を把握して 判断能力があって行動するんです
希望が叶えるように 希望が叶えなかったら
あの忍耐は何の意味もないんです
結果が出なかったら 頑張ったってもアホでしょう
だから 頑張る時は必ず結果が出ることを考えなくちゃあかんです
結果が出そうもなければ
頑張る仕方はいろいろ調整するんです
それが忍耐というんです
だから忍耐って日本語の言葉より
シャンティという落ち着きということがぴったし当てはめるんです
落ち着きなんです 本当の意訳は
直訳は忍耐 忍耐というのは何か嫌なことに対する対応でしょ
そうじゃないんです 落ち着きなんです
はい 次 ティティッカという言葉を説明します
意味は少々狭い ティティッカの
堪忍とは悪状況を乗り越えることです
怒りに対する対応です
邪魔をされたり 反対されたり
非難を受けたり受けたり
いじめ 侮辱 暴力 弾劾を受けたりする
その時耐え忍ぶことはティティッカです
私たちの道で邪魔も入ります
いじめもあります 侮辱もされます
攻撃も受けます こういうのは悪状況なんですね
そうすると怒っちゃうでしょ
アイスに邪魔されたとか
こう怒っちゃうと負け
そこで怒りが湧いてくるところで我慢すること
あるいは対応することは
堪忍というティティッカと言うんです
だから意味が狭いんです
カンティーはすごく広いんです
だから仏教用語はカンティーです
負ける人は怒り 憎しみによって破壊される
他人を攻撃する 雨にも風にも雪にも食べ物にも儒教にも文句を言う
そういう人間いるでしょ
文句ばっかり言って何もやらない
あの人々にはティティッカがないんです
悪口言ってやらないことにする
我慢しろよと そんなのはと
すべて他人の 怒り せいにする
これ正しいかどうか 何でこんな感じになっちゃったっけ
私はつかまない感じなんですけど
で 他人のせいにしたがる
あの人のせいで 学校の先生のせいで勉強できなかったとかね
お母さんが仕事をしたんだから
私に勉強できなかったとかね
お母さんが私は小学校の時離婚してたんだから
俺が勉強できなかったとか
いやいうこと そこを何とかすれば
学校が悪くたっても 先生が悪くたっても
いじめられたくたっても成長できますよ
そうやって悪状況に負けないで
怒りで対応しないで頑張っちゃう
それがティティッカっていう言葉なんです
この人は何も成功しない
敗者ですね 他人をせいにしたら敗者です
怒りです 用語はカンティーです
カンティーには落ち着くという意味もあります
忍耐という意味だけではありません
何が起きても 心を常に冷静に保って
自分が決めたことを全うするように
理性に基づいて努力することがカンティーです
いいでしょう 別に簡単だから
次に行きます 忍耐の活用法
良い条件 良い仲間を獲得
忍耐ってそういうものですね
良い条件 良い仲間 自分の目的に助けてくれる人々を獲得することも忍耐
自分の進み具合をチェックする
どうですか？進んでうまくいっているのかと
この自分の進み具合もチェックする
状況に応じて激しく励んだり
穏やかに励んだり 場合に応じて休んだりもする
がむしゃらに頑張るんじゃないんです
結果出るかな 成長しているかなとわかったら
今はがむしゃらにやらなくちゃとかね
今は緩やかにやった方が
今はやっぱり休んだ方がとか出てきますよ
良いことだと勘違いして
欲に欲に誘惑に負けることもあるので
良い条件に注意を払う
これよく大事なことなんですよ
例えば受験勉強すると
お母さんが1時間ごとに食い物を持ってくる
あれやこれやとか考えて作ってくるわ
考えて作ってくれるわ
お母さんが料理世界一下手であっても
子供に対してはすごい真剣に作るんだから
気持ちが入ってるんだから
これ美味しいんですよ
まあ他人じゃなくて子供には
だから子供がお母さんが30分ごとに1時間ごとに食べ物を持ってくる
それ食ったり食ったり食ったりして
こいつは勉強できなくなっちゃって寝ちゃうんです
あの空腹感があると頭が動くんです
だから受験勉強する子供たちは夜食べない方がいいんです
いくら食べ盛りの年であっても
夜食べないでお腹がグーグーと鳴いているんだけど
水だけ飲んで 勉強すれば頭が冴えてくるわ
全部覚えてしまうわ そういうことで
この良い条件なんですが
なんかちょっと 気をつけなくちゃあかん
この頑張ってる人々は時々誘惑に負けるでしょ
あれは良い条件だと勘違いしているんです
例えば ある人は瞑想するとしましょう
ちょこっとしょぴっと寒い
その人はなんか眠気が入ってるんだから
あえて体を寒さにさらして
頑張ってる そこで優しい人が来て
あのね 風邪引いたらあんた修行もできなくなるんだから
この毛布をかけてください
これかけてください じゃあ椅子と作ってあげるぞとかね
コードを外から遠くから持ってきて
外のところにすると ありがとうございますと
よく心配してくれると言って乗っちゃえばどうなるかと
あまりにも暖かくてまた寝ちゃうんです
そういうところなんです
修行する人々だから 結構あのもう体力も必要でしょう
だから結構美味しいご飯作ってあげますよと
あんたは修行だけしてくださいと
行ってものすごくご馳走作ってくれちゃうと
ありがたい気持ちで感謝の気持ちで食っちゃうでしょ
ダメです あれは あれでやられちゃいます
そこでカンティ忍耐が必要なんです
だから この良いと見える条件にも気をつけるんです
だから仏教用語はカンティ忍耐です
あのティティッカ 堪忍はもうただペアだけです
はい 勘違いに注意 設備がそれている道場を好んだり
有名で知られている師匠を追っかけたり
優しいのだと思って人の話に乗ったり
アドバイスなら誰でも良いと節度を超えた柔軟性を持ったりして失敗する場合もあります
結構カンティは難しいんですよ
結構やられますよ 設備がいい道場だから
私は向こうに行って修行しますとか言っちゃうんですよ
行って負けてくるんです
あの師匠 あの何々お坊さんの道
あのお坊さんがアメリカでも有名で
私はそちらに行きますとかね
はい どうぞと 負けてきます
だからそこら辺で 自分で自分の心をチェックしないと
あるいはもう片っ端からあなたどう思いますか？あなたどう思いますか？この瞑想はどうすればいいかといろんな人から聞いたら
あのね いろんな人に聞くの
いえ 私はいろんな人の意見を聞いてしっかりしてる
えらいかっこいい柔軟性でしょ
あれダメなんです あの
私も知ってるある人がいて
もう極端にアホで あまりにもこういうバカバカらしい柔軟性を持って
なんであなたはヴィパッサナー瞑想だけ正しいと思ってるんですか？と
これはけしからんやと
ヒンドゥー教のジャイナ教の瞑想も正しいではないかと
キリスト教の瞑想も正しいではないかと
私はどうぞ行って調べてくださいと言ったんです
頭ちょこっといい人でしたから
いつか負けてくるだろうと思ってたんです
で 負けて帰ったんだけど
もう成長できん状態になっているんです
もうどうしようもないんです
負けてもブッダの道が正しいってことには達してないんです
だからこれはもうアホな人の柔軟性なんです
柔軟性も理性のある人のしかできないんです
はい そういうことで この我々は仲間だ
味方だと思って ちょっと気を緩めたところでもやられる可能性ありますから
このバランスがもう嫌な条件は必ず避ける
これはそんな難しくない
良いと見える条件 も気をつけなくちゃいけない
それで良い条件を選ばなくちゃいけない
結構ややこしい 比較します
ティティッカは悪条件を耐え忍ぶこと
中心的には怒り その仲間の感情を制御すること
怒り 嫉妬 憎しみですね
これはテティカですね
カンティーは欲 怒り 無知という三毒に感染しないように気をつけることです
カンティーは 理性と知恵を中心にして実践することです
状況を判断しながら どうすればうまくいくのかと見ながら
頑張る時は頑張る 手を緩む時は緩む
休む時は休むというしっかりした良い結果が出るようにと調整することがカンティーです
常に冷静な心を保つことですよ
最終的に言えば 常に冷静でいましょうと
解脱の智慧イコールカンティーです
これからはカットもできます
あの 時間的には９時になってきますけどね
ちょっと頭もう一度ちょっと揺すって
新しいことを言おうとするんです
今まで言ったことと違うことを言おうとしているんです
カンティーっていうのは解脱のことなんです
今 やり方のこと言ってたでしょ
ではなくて 解脱にもカンティー
平安 落ち着きと言うんです
ヴィパッサナー実践が成功して
最後の智慧が現れます
ヴィパッサナー実践を行うと
だいたい七つ段階 大雑把で細かく言えば十二とかね
ステップありまして ヴィパッサナーの智慧だけは九つにしていて
結構精密なプログラムなんです
それはあまり説法では言わないし
公に皆様に覚えられるようには言いません
だから私もこれもう頭が悪いんだから言っちゃうんですよ
だから覚えておかないんです
必要な時見て はい 忘れちゃうということにしてるんです
で そこでまあ大雑把で理解してください
智慧がどんどんどんどん上がっていくんです
ヴィパッサナー瞑想で
それで最後の智慧になるんです
それはサンカーラウペッカーニャーナと言います
一切の現象は無常苦無我という
と発見した修行者は 一切の現象に対してシャウペッカーに達します
この場合はシャッというのは使っている
日本語で使っている漢字で冷静に達します
落ち着きに達します もう智慧がものすごい優れているんです
いかなる現象を見ても
苦か無常か無我で見えるんです
何にも頼りにならないと
じゃあまあ落ち着こうということで
究極的な落ち着きが生まれるんです
これは本物です 落ち着くしかないと
それにはサンカルペッカーニャーナとも言うし
カンティーとも言うんです
これがカンティーという智慧です
ということは カンティーで修行を始めて
カンティーで終わっちゃうんです
落ち着いてやろう やろう
やろうと言ったら 本当に落ち着いてしまいます
本物で 次の瞬間悟ります
で 水準忍耐 なんかわからない単語ですね
これは注釈書やら経典で使っている
また専門用語ですね わからなくてもいいんです
別に これ お釈迦様が使っている用語です
お釈迦様は皆様に喋るときじゃなくて
すごい修行者たちだけ集めて喋るとき使う単語なんです
これはアヌローミカ・カンティーと言うんです
アヌローミカっていうのは水準
カンティーは忍耐 だから水準忍耐
解脱に推進した智慧のことです
前説明 前のスライドでやったことです
一切の現象 業というんですね
サンカーラ 無常苦無我であると発見するとき
起こる智慧はカンティー忍耐です
それは水準忍耐とも言います
アヌローミカ・カンティーに達した修行者はサンマットニアマンオッカミッサティーティ
法則が決まった道に入りますとは直訳です
だから忍耐を完成したら道に入りますよと
この道が違うんです 決まった道
定めた道 もうもう定めています
すごく違う意味なんです
確実に解脱に達する道っていう意味です
このアヌローミカ・カーンティ
随順忍耐が生まれたら
カクンと次の道に入ってドカンと解脱に達する
もうどうすることもできない
瞬間で起こるんです 次の瞬間に預流果
一来果 不還果 阿羅漢果
どちらかに達します より悟ります
なんで四つも書いたのか
それお釈迦様がおっしゃったんだから
四つも書いちゃったんです
我々は一つも悟りは何もない人は一来果に達します
また修行すると 一来果は修行すると
カンテに達したら 預流果が修行するとカーンティに達したら一来果になる
また修行を始めたら不還果になる
また修行を始めたら阿羅漢果になるということなんです
どちらにしてもアヌローミカ・カーンティがあって
随順忍耐があって 次サンマッタニーアマン
定めた道に入って 次の瞬間悟りなんです
忍耐完成の次の瞬間は解脱です
ということで終了ではないかなと思います
あ 終了ですね はい そういうことで一旦話は終了します
時間があるならばということで
私はまたいくつか持ってきましたけど
あのカーンティ忍耐っていうのはただ単に我慢することではなくて
仏教で このヴィパッサナー
これはあの仏教の智慧を説明するテキストからね
経典の注釈から取ったんですけど
この随順忍耐に対して小中大って 3つありましてね
ヴィパッサナー瞑想をしていると
いくつかの智慧に達するんですね
この智慧に智慧に合わせて忍耐がます結構生まれて
さらに瞑想すると新しい智慧が現れて
さらに忍耐が強くなって
さらに修行するとウペッカーナーというものに達したら
強烈な忍耐が生まれてすぐに悟ってしまっちゃうということで
まあやめます 説明は あまりこの専門的なところに行っちゃうと
私の頭も はい そういうことで話は終了です
どうします？まあ時間も時間ですけど
ありがとうございます
えっと  15 分ぐらいなんですけど
ちょっと時間がありますので
もし質問などありましたら
ちょっとマイクを今持ってまいりますので
ちょっと挙手していただければ
どうでしょうか 早く帰りたいですよね
遅いし あ じゃあ前の  どうもこんにちは
初めて来たんですけど
ずっと聞きたかったことがあったんですけど
なんで仏教の人たちはみんな坊主なんですか？ いや
あのね 仏教の人みんな坊主じゃないんです
そうなんです 出家してる人だけです
これは誰が始めたとか
そういうのは歴史的に何かあるんですか？ あれはお釈迦様が始めたんです
まあそれはあのね 我々はサロンに行かなくてもいいんだからね
だって昔はね あの 今と違ってね
シラミが出たり それから髪の毛伸ばしちゃった後
髪型は問題になってくるでしょ
それ煩悩になりますね
剃っちゃえば全部終わり
いたって簡単でね そういう理由なんです
そんな難しい理由はないんです
健康と清潔そう それから面倒くさいことは極力やめる
例えば心もこれだけで
だからデザインは気にする必要ないし
色にも困りません 決まってる色でね
だからその点で皆様よりすごく楽なんです
そちらに至ってもね この上のシャツと中のものは色が合わなかったら困るでしょう
そういう問題は我々にはないんです
はい  ありがとうございました
では ちょっと後ろの私
目が悪いのでよく見えないんですけど
後ろの方ですね ちょっと回していきます
今日はありがとうございました
落ち着いていることが大事ということなんですが
その落ち着いていたくても
どうしてもすぐに怒ってしまう人
なんかその感情がコントロールできないというか
どうしてもすぐ怒ってしまう人
どういうことを意識していったらいいのかっていう
何かアドバイスがあればぜひ教えてください
うん それって簡単ですよ
負けたいあんたは 結局あんた負けたくないでしょ？そこは負けたくはないと思ってください
怒ったら負けますからね
だからあのまだまだ未熟だから怒りますよ
これは問題ではありません
誰だって未熟ですからね
徐々に成長すればいいでしょ
だからといって負けていいわけじゃないでしょ
そういうわけで 落ち着きます
落ち着きますと頑張っても落ち着きが消えちゃう
消えちゃったら あら これなら負けるぞと言ってください
これならこれなら失敗するぞと自分に言ってください
それで回復します はい
ありがとうございます
えっと あと一人ぐらい
では 今回します そうです
えーと すみません 最近ちょっと苦しんでたことでお聞きしたかったんですが
親との関係で苦しんでおります
親がですね ちょっと自分の思い通りにならないことを数えて
なんか心が溺れてるような状態にあると思うんですが
そういう親にもやっぱりもう年老いてきたことですし
心安らかに最期を迎えてもらいたいと思って
僕自身もそういう親が苦しみがなくなってほしいと自分自身でも思うんですけれども
結局自分に何ができるのかといっても
正直無力だなと思って
慈悲の瞑想をサボってきちゃったからというわけじゃないんですけど
真面目にやろうと思ってもやりきれない踏ん切りの悪い自分なので
どういう心の持ち方であれば
そのまず慈悲の瞑想ということから真面目にできるようになるのか
その心構えをちょっと教えていただければと思って質問いたしました
よろしくお願いします
あまり偉そうな大胆なことをする必要はないし
それをやめてください
ただ 思い通りにいかないなとか
それだけ現実でしょ だからそればっかりもうおんぶ返しみたいな感じでお父さんに言ってください
またいつだって やっぱり思い通りにいかないね
苦しいですねとかね やっぱりねとかね
あれ これはね できないねとか
いつでもそんな感じで
やっぱりね 思い通りにいかないなぁとかね
美味しいもの食べたいんだけど
やっぱりね それ食べられないね
苦しいねとかね そういう風に同じ現実をリピートすると
それはお父様の瞑想になるんです
ありのままに 立ちたいんだけど立てない
すごく苦しいんで腹が立ったりする
お父さんがね その場合はそうですね
やっぱり怒りますね これが
とかね ただ認めて認めてあげるだけ
例えば最後だから何かあれ食べたいな
うーん やっぱりね そうですね
食べたいですね でも食べられないね
苦しいですね これって悔しいね
お父さんとかね そういう風に同じ状況を生放送してあげるんです
現実を何もしようとしない
それで本人がやっぱりね
怒っちゃってもねっていう感じになるだろうと思います
それで落ち着きます 他やることはないと思いますよ
あんたは一人で慈悲の瞑想してください
それはまあ お父さんの心にも添うし
自分の心も穏やかになるし
お父様に何かしてあげたいというならば
お父様の代わりに現状を実況中継してあげる
はい 以上です ありがとうございました
それでは時間がちょうど切ってしまいましたので
これで終了したいと思います
はい 最後に  あ ちょっと待って
最後に皆様に新しい芸を紹介したいと思います
これは我々はだいたい何か法事があった時は
みんなで一斉に唱える芸なんですね
だから 仏教にとって何者の方もこれからも理解できる
我々はどんな気持ちで来ているのかと
私は今日もう朝ではなくて
ちょっとこちらへ来るちょこっと前にささっと書きましたから
日本語訳はまだ直してないんです
で しかし スリランカの場合は子供も覚えている
ちっちゃな子供まで覚えている芸なんです
我々はシンハラ語で歌にもして
パーリ語 シンハラ語両方合わせて唱えますから
じゃあ私と一緒に唱えてください
ドッカッパッターチェニンンッカ
バヤンパッターチェニンバヤ
スーカッパッターチェニススーカ
ホントゥサンビーピパーニノ
一緒に 苦しむものの苦しみがなくなりますように
怯えるものの怯えが消えますように
悲しむものの悲しみが消えますように
一切の生命が過去のごとくありますように
はい ありがとうございます
はい